talking about you know touching grass
and we're going going on like adventures
and everything like that I think I get
Slice of Life anime now
like it's just could you repeat that I
think I think I think I get it now
because every time like welcome to the
club
finally a fellow Slice of Life enjoy
right here because like
you know I mean it's just like that it's
like I can't believe you've done this
it's so goddamn boring so boring because
like oh watch someone [ __ ] make [ __ ]
I don't watch a YouTube tutorial anime
like what the [ __ ] I mean a lot of
people do like that but no explain why
I'll explain I'll explain because for
for the longest time I didn't really
like I didn't really like understand the
appeal of like watching a lot of Slice
of Life anime like you're special like
yasuke and stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah
um and then me and Sydney like we we've
I've talked about this before we have
this yearly trip to yamanashi where we
explore it's like it's really really
quiet area we explore the area and
something and most of the most of the
time we just do nothing we're just like
kind of just
chill and just take in the atmosphere
there's not much to do in yeah yeah
there's nothing to do not mind there's
not much to do you can drink wine that's
it yeah that's all you drink wine and
watch my mouth Fuji that's right yeah
you can drink wine and just take in the
atmosphere and I'm just like that is me
that is me I'm not complaining because
that's what I like yeah yeah I'm a fan
of both those yeah and I'm just like
damn it's fun doing nothing you know it
feels really really good just having
this nice experience of just like just
like yeah kind of just doing nothing and
just taking the dance taking the
environment in right let's go to that
and I'm like damn I felt this somewhere
before why have I felt this before Oh
this is the exact same feeling I get
when I watch every [ __ ] Slice of Life
anime like why is it fun to watch people
doing nothing yeah yeah and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I think I get anything I'm
watching people do nothing no no no it's
it's this idea I think the appeal of
Slice of Life comes from there where
it's like you know I think a lot of the
reason why science lab especially in
Japan is so popular is because the main
demographic of people who watch Slice of
Life are people who have nine to fives
super busy schedules yeah always working
always have something on their mind and
their one Escape is to just be have this
Mutual feeling of I'm doing nothing but
it's relaxing yeah right and maybe they
themselves don't want to be in a
position where you know maybe they don't
have the money all the time to actually
go out to the you're not going I wonder
because that's in my head when I still
watch anime it's like my brain is being
engaged right yeah yeah I'm still even
even watching Slice of Life though yeah
even watching really yeah because I'm
watching it and I'm like this is still
doing more than nothing oh no in my head
when I was Slice of Life I am like brain
tone off mode I'm just like I'm just
like watching moving images
I don't to me I'm watching it I'm like
this is requiring effort to watch yeah
and I I'm I'm just bored yeah because it
gives me like it just gives me that like
same relaxing freeing feeling I'm trying
to like verbalize kind of the you know
kind of the experience you get when you
go to a place like this in the middle of
nowhere Japan because I'm sure there are
other place like it's it's it's it's not
it's off of Japan it's like that I
believe 40 out of the 47 prefectures I
like that nearly all of the prefectures
I'm I'm not like I'm not trying to say
that oh doing nothing and taking the
environment that's a Japanese thing only
Japanese people have figured out how to
do that you know but they've certainly
perfected it though they have certainly
perfected it it's it's definitely what
I'm saying they're like we have
optimized doing nothing
no I get it it's like I just think like
I think the word you're looking for is
like
what I like about it's again it's like
that feeling of like
um because you know I think in a lot of
ways like for me what I like about Slice
of Life is that a lot of Slice of Life
is you know based around a lot of like
the the inaka and like you know in the
mountains of Japan or like in places
where there's like not a whole lot
happening and so yeah the countryside
yeah like the country sorry and all
these characters have to find a way to
do certain things and for me it's kind
of special because I spent a lot of my
childhood like that in Japan like when
my grandma lived in the middle but [ __ ]
nowhere in Miyagi we had to make our own
fun like we were just surrounded by rice
fields we were like all right the [ __ ]
are we doing today right so I think I
relate heavily to that feeling and it's
like kind of looking at my childhood
through like roasting the glasses in a
sense but like even as an adult I
sometimes watch Slice of Life you know
like I recently uh you know caught up on
like Euro Camp right yeah and I'm like
why is this still fun to watch for me
even though technically nothing is
happening it's because again it's it's
like that feeling of like being content
with the fact that nothing's happening
but that's what's so nice about it I I
think because I've realized I I don't
know what it is about Japan right but
Japan has just perfected Vibes unlike it
just no matter where you go whether it's
like the city or the countryside smoking
like a true Instagram all right it's
just literally that Tick Tock meme in
Japan it's just [ __ ] Vibes right I I
don't know why I don't know why I wonder
if that's because you never had the time
or disposable income in the UK to going
on these trips
maybe I don't know because there are
some places in Europe and the UK that
are pretty [ __ ] chilled too oh no
yeah I'm not saying this is a Japan only
thing right I'm just I'm just saying
that Japan
it's it's so easy it's so easy to find
in Japan yeah
[Music]
you know yeah it's like I had a [ __ ]
time of soft bank so you know what I'm
gonna do to wind down watch some Slice
of Life
I think how you're describing how you
view size of life that's how I watch
documentaries right right it turns my
brain off yeah and I just listen really
I wonder if that's how people watch
Trash taste
we might be a slice of Life show to some
people yeah because I you know I just
watch documentaries I leave them on the
background sometimes I don't really need
to focus and it kind of makes me zone
out and kind of chill out yeah in a
weird way don't know why but how you
describe it's a slice of life that's how
it sounds to me but Slice of Life for me
to stress me out that nothing's
happening and it stresses me out that
they're not doing anything right but
it's not moving yeah I think like for
example like that's why I really enjoyed
non-numbiory because like that is like
what my childhood was like in a lot of
ways right like when I was visiting
Japan that's just what it was yeah you
go out with your friends you'd find your
own fun like nothing [ __ ] happens at
the end of the day but it was still good
it makes you feel this kind of like
yearning Nostalgia even if you've never
grew up in Japan yeah you know
absolutely and that's kind of that's
kind of like what I feel even though
have no [ __ ] roots in Japan but
watching these shows and especially
going to places like this I'm like why
do I feel nostalgic even though I have
no attachment to this place you know
yeah and it's it's it's super it's weird
super weird it's super weird but like I
said like I said like Japan is a country
of Vibes and I think there's a reason
why it's become one of the most
instagramable countries on Earth you
know like I'm not saying like I said I'm
not like trying to like hype Japan up to
be like oh you're like normal things
Japanese thing right you know like but
it's funny because in a lot of ways it's
true for a lot of people in a lot of
ways it is true I don't know why this
country is so [ __ ] aesthetic whether
it be like I remember I remember
randomly I think it was like when we
went to the [ __ ] junka delic the last
time right with all three of us yeah and
uh it's this you know Mexican placing
um uh in nakamegara that we've talked
about in past trash Fest episode well
like last time we went you know we had
this [ __ ] amazing you know Mexican
meal and then as we were walking back
from juncadelic to nakamego station I
remember God just randomly just stopped
and went
why is Japan so [ __ ] aesthetic it's
just like out loud I'm like you good
yeah it's just like that country where
no matter what angle you take you just
you just like snap a picture instantly
instagramable you know and it doesn't
matter
yeah you go to like a place like golden
guy and I'm just like [ __ ] this this
looks cool this looks so [ __ ] like a
lot of this stuff does look cool yeah
and I'm like that looks totally
different from like just going out to
the countryside and it's just it's a
different kind of vibe but it still
Vibes exactly it's still Vibes basically
Japan is like Lo-Fi the country I just I
that's why I slice of life that's like
the Lo-Fi hip-hop playlist
ages ago Silver Spoon oh yeah I hated it
really oh I love I love it I thought
something was gonna happen I love silver
and nothing happened
and I was like what the [ __ ] I love it
because what is the point I love it
because nothing happens
that's just [ __ ] storytelling did
something happen but that's the point
they're not it's it's like how you make
a story with no story yes like what they
perfected and it's like who wanted this
well that's like that's like going on to
a Lo-Fi playlist and being like Oh the
musicianship is [ __ ] no I like that it's
like it's like it's like oh there's
there's no musicianship in this
whatsoever It's like because they're not
trying I I admire people who enjoy Slice
of Life I feel like there's just a
mental barrier that is stopping me from
enjoying this whole genre
um and I don't understand yeah and I
yeah I just I just felt like annoyed
when I I think I watched like four
episodes of Silver Spirit why'd you
waste my time
like I thought I thought something was
gonna happen right so before I knew it
was a genre yes yes so I watched it and
I was like waiting for some plot yeah
how do you say that because I think
Silver Spoon is one of the best Slice of
Life
in terms of the job in terms of what the
genre has to offer yeah well I I think
you have to be in it you definitely have
to be in a certain mood to watch slices
what mood no Story please I want no
Story the mood to just zone out and just
Revel in like just a nice comfy feeling
I mean if you ask me why I zone out
documentaries I'm like I don't know I
don't know see because I'm the opposite
with documentaries I'm forced to listen
and my it's like an active thing because
I want to understand what's happening I
feel like I've watched so many
documentaries now where
the formulas feel so familiar that I'm
like okay I can kind of figure out
everything that's going on right very
quickly I feel for a lot of people's
Slice of Life I guess is like the the
comfort food of anime right where it's
like it's like I don't want to think
about it I just I know I like this thing
even though it doesn't you know offer me
anything new in terms of an experience
right it's just like it's just something
to have because I like it and that's
fine I think what's really nice about
slice of life is just it's a nice escape
from just the Daily Grind of life you
know it's you you get away from that
daily ground because what you do
normally I may not do that oh does
normal anime not give you the Escape of
a no because it puts you into I feel a a
world that is not maybe not the same in
terms of like the quality but in terms
of like the the just the amount of [ __ ]
that's going on it's like that's another
thing you have to like follow and
maintain and you know understand right
yeah like you know you'd watch any
Shonen and be like okay there's a world
and there are these characters involved
in this world that have to do certain
things and there's this evil thing and
blah blah blah right there's so many
that's engaging right and and it's like
I'm not saying that's bad or anything
like but I need to be in a mood
sometimes I'm in a mood where I'm like
yes I want something that has a
convoluted story with a convoluted
characters convoluted relationships but
sometimes I don't want to think about
that [ __ ] sometimes I just want to turn
my brain off and watch cute girls doing
cute things
do you ever go on trips and just do
nothing every ship I do is nothing right
so why do you enjoy that
turn your brain off you know you finally
get to uh there you go there's the
answer but like I don't get that from
watching some people go on trips some
people watch less I wish I wish I could
do that from a TV show but I think
that's but I think that's why a lot of
it's a different kind though like just
my brain of watching a documentary is
not the same as going on a trip and yeah
yeah just relaxing and not thinking
about anything but I guess that's why
you know there might be a reason why
Slice of Life is so popular in Japan
it's because some people you know who
work the salary man life yeah who work
the nine to five six days a week can't
afford to go on these also yeah
sometimes it's just about like it's
about the small things you know it is
like okay
like the smallest interaction can bring
you likes okay so actually I'm just like
I just remembered like something that
happened to me on this trip I know just
like it just it was just such a such a
nice by the way my argument is not
though don't watch Slice of Life go
outside I
for me I don't know maybe it's the older
I'm getting
um and the more I my uh likes and what I
want is revolved more about actually
going outside yeah doing stuff no I
totally get that as well I don't know
why maybe there's some scientific reason
that when I you know because I should be
like online 24 7. and I'd never want to
do anything else yeah but now I don't
know if it's I don't know if it's about
a job or what that we're online all the
time that's that's a big reason why I
don't watch as much anime as I used to
because like for me now it's like yes
there's a part of it where it's like
yeah sometimes I have enjoyment from
watching anime and there's sometimes
where I do want to watch anime like you
know I wanted to finish Euro camp and I
did and it was great but now I have
other interests where a lot of it
involves me going outside and doing real
life stuff yeah and it's like is that me
falling out of anime or is that just me
growing up as a person and my interests
change I don't yeah I don't know I don't
know yeah I mean going back to slice of
life I still don't like every Slice of
Life like oh yeah yeah I still will
never ever ever be able to get into
chaon for example
don't you dare [ __ ] slander
I feel so boring I feel like there's
only a handful of Slice of Life that
that I actually enjoy and I've noticed a
pattern that all every Slice of Life I
enjoy are like replications of stuff
that I've experienced before yes like
I've never been a cute anime girl
drinking tea and you know like trying to
form I mean I've had apart from the
forming a band bit that's the uh that's
the only thing I can relate to so
whenever it's anything but that I'm like
don't get it no but I don't get it but
that's why I enjoyed chaon because I
have those memories of forming a band
and hanging out with Bandits granted
none of us were cute anime girls and
none of us drank tea you know we did
other things instead of that but that
that feeling of like you know just doing
cool musical [ __ ] together with a group
of friends and the troubles and you know
small turmoils that at the end of the
day don't really [ __ ] matter because
he's just a bunch of kids all right like
that's the part of K on that I connected
with and that's why I enjoyed it [ __ ] it
I saw chaotic like pissed me off I'm
like you're trying to trying to stop
Banning or eating tea and drinking like
you're you're eating cake drinking tea
every [ __ ] day no wonder your music
career is [ __ ] but I do do some [ __ ]
work just a [ __ ] bad practice man
Jesus Christ come on see I can't get mad
at that because that's exactly how my
high school bands went I think we
practice maybe 15 minutes most of the
time we're just [ __ ] around my band
practice like when okay in like fully
wire band never popped in my in my band
experience it was this is my [ __ ] bad
experience yeah had nowhere to like
practice our instruments right because
we lived in the city and you can't make
some you can't make noise so we had to
hire out a studio in order to like in
order to also time mattered yeah so time
[ __ ] matter yeah we had two hours to
practice we are [ __ ] right in [ __ ] we
were [ __ ] practicing we were like
booking our next get them big and
working towards that so I was just like
no there is no time to [ __ ] around no
for me it was for me it was oh it's the
weekend let's go to the drummer's house
because the drum set's already there
what up a big [ __ ] mattress on the
doors and the wall so that it's like
sound proof practice for maybe I don't
know an hour and then just my friend
being like you want to go play the new
Mario Kart yeah let's go do that
that was our band practice so I'm like
you know what you know what you know
what Hawk has a tea time I relate I
relate I'm not drinking tea but I'm
playing some [ __ ] money is probably
the most alien thing to me in existence
it's like I don't get like like in uh
you know giving them obsessed with cute
anime girls yeah
I don't like music and I don't like
Slice of Life yeah it's like the
trifecta of all the things I don't like
about anime
and so that's true when people are like
dude you gotta watch Kyle and I'm like
it looks awful for me like this looks
like the worst thing I could watch it
probably is for you yeah like this is
torture yeah yeah 100